two presidents two different kinds of Frontline
visit rival leaders in Russia's war on Ukraine
seeking to bolster troops in embattled
territory facing very different problems
President Putin making a rare trip outside
of Russia to the partially occupied region of
her son in video released by the Kremlin
he's pictured meeting senior commanders
Monday it is important for me to listen
to you to hear your views to compare notes
who he talks to is also important
apparently meeting a commander of
elite paratroopers in what western analysts
say could be a bid to shore up their morale
any day now Ukraine is expected to launch a
counter-offensive pretty much in the direction
of where he's standing Putin also stopping
in lahansk also under pressure and just last
week shifted onto moscow's time zone as Russia
continues to assimilate places its war is ravaging
cave officials quick to seize on the visit to
portray a person indicted for war crimes returning
to the scene describing the trip as a special
tour of the occupied and destroyed territories
by our Mastermind of mass murders to savor one
last time the crimes committed by his people
solenski perhaps enduring greater risk in his less
rare journey to some of the worst hit parts of the
Eastern Front visiting the almost completely
destroyed town of abdifka handing out Awards
to troops it won't yet be clear if he boosted
morale enough to hold back the Russian forces
now on three sides of the Town things happen
thanks to you take care our future depends on you
Ukraine's losses are mounting some of the injured
visited by zelenski and Donetsk region too
recent leaked documents apparently from the
Pentagon suggested over 15 000 Ukrainian troops
were dead and that they might run out of key air
defense systems in the coming weeks if Kiev hopes
its better equipment cause and planning may
see success in this vital counter-offensive
two presidents two wildly different souls
and one war still Without End Nick Payton
Walsh CNN eastern Ukraine meanwhile the U.S is
sending Russia a Stern warning about sensitive
American Technology at Ukraine's and zaporizia
nuclear power plant which Russia Now controls
the message is don't touch it in a letter to the
Russian agency overseeing the plant's operations
the U.S says export controls forbid any Russian
from handling that technology no response so far
from Moscow cnnada Bashir joins us now live from
London I mean not that even if Russia was going
to pay attention to that letter I mean there's
no way to actually enforce this that would be a
good faith gesture of trust of the Russians not to
poke around this technology yeah absolutely I mean
this uh nuclear power plant it's the largest
in Europe and is still operated by Ukrainian
staff but crucially it falls under the control of
the Russian armed forces and Russia's state-owned
energy firm rossitam so really this isn't going
to have a significant impact on the ground because
it is under the control and under the territory
that is now occupied by the Russian Armed Forces
now we've heard in that letter which has been
reviewed by CNN the U.S department of energy
saying that this is Aboriginal nuclear power
plant contains quote U.S origin nuclear and
Technical data that is export controlled by the
US government so that essentially means it would
be unlawful for any Russian citizens or Russian
entities to handle this technology and this is
of course a huge concern for the US Government
we've seen since Russia's invasion of Ukraine
this operation nuclear power plant coming under
attack we've seen the power plant disconnected
from the Ukrainian National Grid on multiple
occasions as a result of Russian selling and
that has really raised concerns over the potential
for a nuclear accident in Europe and of course
the last time we saw these public discussions
about U.S technology and Russia's temptation
to explore it would be the Downing of the Reaper
drone when there was a Race Against Time to try
and recover that drone in the Black Sea to find
out more information about it thank you so much